على مدار اكثر من عقدين تصدر الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان كل الانتخابات التي شهدتها
تركيا واختتمها بفوزه بولايه رئاسيه ثالثه
فوز فتح باب التساؤل حول كيفيه تغلب
اردوغان على العراقيل التي واجهته على
راسها الاقتصاد والزلزال وتحدي المعسكر
الغربي
داخليا حاول اردوغان جذب اصوات ناخبين
خاصه الشباب رغم ترد الاقتصاد عبر تقديم
وعود بخلق سته ملايين وظيفه وتحقيق معدلات
نمو عاليه واعطاء دفعه كبيره للسياحه
وتوفير انترنت مجاني وهواتف دون ضريبه
وبنصف الثمن
المعارضه عولت على الزلزال لخساره اردوغان
الا ان الاخير استطاع امتصاص غضب الناجين
عبر التحرك على ارض الواقع سريعا ببناء
21,244 وحده سكنيه موزعه على احدى عشره
ولايه منكوبه وتعهدات بوضع اساسات
244 الف وحده سكنيه اخرى بغضون شهرين
اضافه الى منح تقدم للطلاب الذين فقدوا
اقارب جراء زلزال
وفي محاوله لدعم المواطنين الاتراك
بمواجهه الاوضاع المعيشيه الصعبه رفع
الرئيس التركي الحد الادنى للاجور ثلاث
مرات خلال سنه ووعد بتوفير غاز طبيعي
للمنازل بالمجان
الرئيس التركي حاول الاستفاده من النزعه
القوميه لمواطنيه عبر تعزيز صورته كقائد
عالمي مؤثر مستغلا جهود بلاده بالوساطه في
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه وتسليطه الضوء
على قدرات بلاده الدفاعيه بتوفير اسلحه
وصنع اول سفينه حربيه محليه الى جانب
استغلاله تاثير بلاده في حلف شمال الاطلسي
لعرقله ملف انضمام السويد للحلف عوامل
ساهمت وفق مراقبين في فوز اردوغان بولايه
رئاسيه ثالثه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات